one of the great problems in the world
is also one of the most invisible
because by its nature it asks to be
hidden and saps our ability to spot its
symptoms but to generalize grossly few
things so undermine human wellbeing as
the sickness of shame the guilty feel
bad for something specific they have
done if ashamed feel wretched simply for
being the affliction lacks borders
ashamed people we don't connect the
myriad ways in which our behavior and
feelings are driven by a base conviction
of our own up Horan's we just take it as
a given that we are disgusting we lack
the capacity to imagine that our shame
as a history and therefore perhaps a
future that could be curtailed a first
step in untangling ourselves is to get
enough distance to spot and name the
problem we might make use of a little
questionnaire out of 10 rate how true
the following statements feel I don't
deserve to exist
I am defective I am unworthy of being
known and loved I am a mistake I deserve
to be abandoned I should not be anything
over an 8 starts to indicate the problem
but if there were an option most of us
in the shamed camp would want to award
ourselves a hundred or more this is the
windswept barren land of shame where
many of us have been living all our
lives often without enough mental
well-being to know that this is where
we've been relegated we should probe but
wear our shame collapse take the outline
of a human figure what are we ashamed of
our mind facial appearance physique
genitals anus we were not born ashamed
we should summon up the voices that gave
us our legacy and which we have then
internalized and blended with our own
you'll never amount to anything you're
the family idiot you disgust me
may wonder why people around us behaved
this way the answer is clear enough to
the shamed because we deserved it
we wouldn't be truly shamed people if
all it took was a few simple questions
to shake us from our conviction of our
detestable identity we were shamed
because we were an are defective our
caregivers weren't mean they were above
anything else
perceptive even brilliant they could
spot things that later kind of people
cannot they had the true measure of us
shamed children don't blame their
Guardians we protect them for a weird
but logical reason so as not to feel
entirely alone we prefer to think well
of our caregivers than to take on board
how badly we've been let down with all
the convulsive rage and sadness that
would entail the consequences of shame
are written across our lives we don't
allow other people to get too close to
us they would only be appalled if they
knew the true us we're not so good on
physical intimacy we get scared all the
time
bad things happen to bad people we don't
like parties why would anyone be pleased
to see us we have a lot of secrets for
most of what we are is unacceptable to
other eyes we go in for addictive
behavior to escape our self-hatred then
feel even more ashamed of ourselves for
the unholy things we've done what is the
way out of shame the same popular answer
is to tell ourselves that we are
beautiful and good but that when easily
convinced us there may be a better more
oblique strategy to bypass the defenses
of the shamed we should stress not that
we are wonderful but that every human
being who has ever walked the planet is
in their own way radically imperfect and
broken when observed from close up we
may be a bit wrong but so blessedly is
everyone else who is and has ever been
we can be stupid perverted and uncouth
but that is wholly normal rather than
implicitly upholding an ideal of
goodness by telling ourselves that we do
after all measure
to it far better to throw away ideals
and all notions of achievable purity and
goodness that's where the problems
started better to accept that we are as
a group entirely crazy and ill-tempered
wicked and odd but then to stress just
how much this is a reason for mercy and
kindness
rather than censure and condemnation
let's stop judging ourselves and others
by unreal standards that's how we made
ourselves ill that's laughs and comfort
each other for the absurdity and horror
of existing in human form the primary
sin of those who made us feel ashamed
was not so much that they spotted our
flaws it's that they forgot their own
awfulness and then had the gall to blame
us for our own we should give up on
fascistic perfectionism in order to make
a generous home for our cracked reality
in our own and in the collective
imagination that'll be the start of our
way out of the problem of shame at the
school of life we believe that
confidence is a skill we can all learn
click now to learn more
you